england's chief inspector of schools has
announced a bold five-year plan she
promises more inspections more research
more intervention in event intervention
to help schools and child care get over
the trauma of lockdown but the mood in
the staff rooms and at the school gates
is fractious can amanda spillman
convince teachers and parents she's the
person to safeguard the interests of
children and she's with me now in the
studio amanda thanks so much for coming
in
i wanted to start with
covid and where we are now at school in
schools as a country we've been
encouraged to move past the pandemic to
get people back to work back to normal
do you believe there will be long-term
consequences in the state school system
because of covid around the pandemic
and also the lack of funding sufficient
funding for kids to catch up i do think
there will be consequences um at one
level we're back to normal schools
aren't operating with covert covert
restrictions lockdowns bubbles all the
rest of it but it's been an incredibly
tough couple of years um heads teachers
are weary they've been working so hard
and a great many children have really
struggled it's been very very tough for
them so while everybody's back in school
there's a lot to catch up on and it's
really hard work with really tired
people so absolutely there's a lot of
effects still to come through and amanda
your job obviously is to inspect schools
and look at standards so kevin collins
who you'll know he was briefly the prime
minister's education czar
back in the moment when the government
was talking about schools and recovery
he asked for 15 billion pounds to help
put funding into schools to help kids in
state schools catch up and in the end
the government i think offered up about
three billion in additional funding when
he stood down he said i do not believe
it will be possible to deliver a
successful recovery without
significantly greater support than the
government has to date indicated it
intends
to provide
do you agree with him
i'd like to wind a step back and talk
about the ways in which covid has
affected children
we've got some children who are really
catching up um pretty well in the normal
classroom with their normal teachers
making accelerated progress
that's quite a large proportion actually
so i don't think we should be too
pessimistic overall but of course we've
got some
who for all sorts of reasons are a lot
further behind and structured
intervention um to help them is really
important a great deal of that
comes from the school's own staff in
fact one of the things we've seen
about tutoring about all the tutoring
that schools are putting place with the
national tutoring program is they've
actually got a strong preference for
using their their own staff
over staff supplied from other sources
so actually it's interesting that
schools want to work with their own
resource if they possibly can
and i think a great deal of good of
really good tutoring and catch-up
interventions is being organized that
way
so i'm not as pessimistic as some
um what we are we are working on this
we're looking for having had a point do
you think kevin collins
but there was also a question because
one of the things that's transpired is
it's actually been quite difficult to
find enough tutors and to find the right
tutors who can tie in so if there had
been a huge amount of extra money in
school budgets i'm not sure that we
would have had extra tutors to spend it
all on
so the most important thing is to do it
really really well and have it very
tightly integrated with what happened
amanda let me put it another way because
we're also seeing and you'll know this
the gap between state school funding and
private school funding almost double
this
investment money going into school fees
for private schools
funding per pupil dropping in real terms
in england as head of offstead are you
concerned by this growing inequality
between education
it seems that there's been an arms race
in the private sector for years right
somebody builds a theater somebody else
has to build an even grander sports
pitch the facilities race
in the private sector has been quite
extraordinary i think a lot of that's
been about attracting people from
overseas i don't think it bears any
relationship to what happens in the
state system here or or anywhere else
come to that and i also don't think it's
necessarily has a great deal to do with
the education i don't think it you don't
think it it entrenches inequality
between those children that can go to a
private school and those children that
can't it does entrench some undesirable
kinds of equality but if we look across
the world
state systems everywhere in developed
countries are operating with quite
similar amounts of funding english
schools are very much
in the normal range so the first job is
to make sure we use what we've got
really well and think in a very
structured way about curriculum and
teaching and make sure that children
have have the the very best experience
well look well we believe we can make we
make fantastic schools okay well let's
come on to your strategy you put out a
five-year strategy this week to try and
address the devastating impact on the
pandemic with a big focus on the early
years flagging that children
lagging there are children lagging in
communication and languages schools some
of the pretty skills some of the the
preschool kids
is that your your biggest area of
concern when you look across the piece
of early years to secondary education
we've got concerns right through
we've done a particularly large amount
of work on school age and
post post-16 over the last five years
in the light of covid we've seen
particular harm for the youngest
children and remember children who have
just turned two say have lived all their
lives in a pandemic they've seen adults
around them with face masks they've seen
far fewer people than usual it's not
surprising that for so many of them
their language and communication
development are well behind where they
would normally be that their social
skills are less developed so getting
them
back on track has got to be a really big
priority and that's that's why we've put
it right in the center of our new
strategy and as i understand it the
cabinet talked about this week
looking at
cutting child care costs because of the
cost of living crisis by loot diluting
the ratio of adults to kids in early
years education you know that you know
you can one adult at the moment i think
has three children
would you worry about that in the
context of what you're talking about
that actually they need more input is
that a concern to you
i think it's really important um to look
to look to look comparatively here
um i've seen oecd analysis
that says we've got the most generous
staffing ratios in the developed world
um for early education of course there's
a trade-off between between staffing and
cost it's very important that we protect
the quality of education and the quality
of care for children but but but i do
think it's right to look and make to
look to look at it to make to make sure
that we're not goal plating that we're
making that that we've got early
education um as affordable as it can be
as well as
quite really high quality so in
principle you're not opposed to the
loosening of those ratios in principle i
don't think ratios of themselves drive
quality we should look at quality
quality of education quality of care and
safeguarding first and foremost okay
one other thing i wanted to
ask you about in relation to
children's education is something that
the government social mobility
commissioner said yesterday she told a
group of mps that girls shy away from
studying physics because they don't like
hard maths what was your
response to that what do you think of
that i think it was a terribly
unfortunate thing for her to say
it really was
there is an imbalance between girls and
boys it's a rather large imbalance by
the time you get to post 16 study of
subjects like physics and further maths
um i think but i turn it around and say
actually it's telling in some ways it's
telling us something about girls
strengths
so many girls get to age 16 say and find
that they're all around us that they're
equally good at everything
and really struggle to decide what not
to pursue because at that age we do we
do make young people choose
boys by contrast are much more likely
to to be much better at maths and
science than they are at language based
subjects so it's much more likely for
them to be a no-brainer to stick with
the maths and science route
and at one level of course we don't want
to to march children off and say even if
you don't want to do history
to do maths you want to do history
you're not going to do history
but we should be concerned when
disproportionately
girls shut them out shut themselves out
of some of the most interesting some of
the most lucrative and some of the most
socially valuable parts and it's the
technologists and scientists who are
solving climate change a bit of a
foolish thing to say really then given
that i thought the efforts to get girls
into stem subjects there's some
fantastic efforts in hand and of course
we must balance the rights of
individuals um with wider social aims
but yes a very unfortunate thing to say
um
let's get on to to you briefly i've got
i've got lots of other things to ask you
about but
amanda you
are not a teacher by background and
anyone who's a teacher who lives with
the teacher my mum was a teacher so i
remember this the shadow of fear cast by
an offstead inspection she was a head
teacher and believe me it was a painful
period in our house when there was an
ofsted inspection but but with previous
inspectors chris woodhead or michael
wilshaw they were fellow teachers and
you aren't you were someone that was
from the city trained and worked in the
city has that been a barrier for you
with teachers
do you think that sometimes they think
you don't understand the pressures
they're under because you haven't walked
in their shoes
i'm sure that happens sometimes but i
think what people lose sight of
is that it was actually only until my
late 30s that i worked in the city and
then i changed career and i've worked in
education
um since
for the last 20 years
so i did a masters in education and then
i became part of the founding team at
what's now one of the biggest academy
chains so i have lived and breathed
education from the point of view of
somebody um running an academy chain
um really getting into the problems of
the most disadvantaged schools um the
chain i worked for um was particularly
targeted at children with the
the steepest path to climb we were
taking on the toughest schools
working out what curriculum what
teaching were needed working out what it
would take to to turn those schools
around and i was doing that for years
before i came into this job so i have
seen
all the things that can go wrong with
the school and all the things that can
go right with the school at very close
quarters and been working intimately
with the people who are directly
responsible in those schools and amanda
coming on to
working in schools and some of the
the cultural issues around schools
in the u.s there's
been a situation where schools and
curricula is becoming a battleground a
political battleground do you fear that
happening here you recently said that
schools have to tread a careful path
between being damned for being
intolerant or slammed for being woke
what do you mean by that
this country fortunately is is not
polarized at the level of that i think
we're seeing in the united united states
but nevertheless there are some very
very hot political contests and of
course many of those um things that
children become that children become
aware about and so of course it's right
that schools talk about politics talk
about current and topical issues but
there's an important requirement on
schools which is to be politically
impartial and that's that's small p
political it's not about um
um
political political um whether they talk
about conservative or labor or lib dems
it's in the broader sense they've got to
make sure that they give children as a
balanced diet overall and that they
don't teach um think contested ideas as
fact or doctrine and you think they're
doing that or they're in danger of doing
that in
in the main most school
most schools walk this line really well
but it's very hard at the moment because
there are some very passionate voices
and when something is presented as a
sort of moral issue rather than a
political issue it can become hard for
people who are really engaged in in
something that for them is very much a
moral issue to recognize where it's
something
um
what's a good what's a good example
um we did an inspection recently of an
independent school
um which had um a curriculum which was
very much about social justice
and which we did find
didn't meet the political political
political impartiality expectations but
the teachers there very much saw it as
uh that that the moral
value of teaching this curriculum
overrode political impartiality
they found it hard to see that
let me go on to something something else
about gender and schools is it important
that schools maintain single sex
provision for girls using toilets and
changing rooms for example in your view
this is one of the toughest ones for
schools at the moment and it is coming
up more and more and more and we're
hearing about this although it hasn't
come up from inspection much yet we know
it's getting to be a bigger issue in
schools
adolescence is a time when
everybody's exploring sexuality um
increasingly gender all other all kinds
of other aspects of of um
their identity
and schools have to stay on top of that
so they do have to handle children with
gender identity issues sensitively but
um safeguarding children and biological
sex absolutely is and continues to be
relevant right the way through so you
think it does matter to have
single sex provision for girls each
school every school has to work out its
own arrangements but it's important to
recognize that we've got so conflicting
rights here this is not something that
you can steamroll and we have to
acknowledge
that some of the gender issues come
directly into conflict with some of the
sex basically amanda would your message
be to schools uh
that have removed single sex spaces
what's your message then that they
shouldn't
my message is that is that they've got
to make sure that the jet that the very
real tensions here have been air
discussed that they've got buy-in for
whatever solution this is we don't
prescribe what school what schools do
when conflicts between rights arise this
is not the first time that we found
ourselves um in a place where we can see
a clear conflict of rights so so much of
my time at ofsted we've been dealing
with places where religious rights and
sex sex rights conflict and we found
illegal segregation or where religion
and sexuality can flip whereas religious
schools don't want to teach about
homosexuality
i've got one quick question for you on
the issue of single sex schools over 50
of teachers in england have said they
have at least one pupil who's identified
as transgender do you still think single
sex schools will exist in a generation's
time or will society have moved on from
that form of demarcation between people
there are certainly far fewer single sex
schools than there once were but
in a world where parent choice matters
i'd be very reluctant
to see a mandate um that there should be
no no single sex schools yes issues of
gender identity um create some
difficulties at the borderline no
question about that um but i certainly
wouldn't be calling to to obamacare
all right well amanda
we've run out of time thank you that was
fascinating